you've ever listened to a siren
approaching you've heard the familiar
Doppler shift that's interesting Doppler
Christian Doppler and Wolfgang Mozart
grew up in the same town in Salzburg
Austria the irony of that fact that they
both have this fascination with sound
and its phenomena is exactly the result
of a Doppler shift which is exactly
analogous to the increase in pitch and
the decrease in Pitch that one hears
when an ambulance first approaches you
with its siren on that pitch is
increased and that's called a blue ship
meaning it goes to Shorter sound
wavelengths or it goes to higher pitches
as it goes away the opposite phenomena
happens and that's where you hear this
characteristic rise
as it moves away from you and that's an
analog of reg
[Music]
foreign